[Music]
this is a weekend when I'm normally
fishing down on Martha's Vineyard and
when I do that I easily go fishing with
a good friend of mine and we spend most
of the time talking and relative a
little of it fishing and as we talk he
often reminisces about meaningful times
in his own life among his most vivid
recollections where his experience is
playing football now in American
football as most of you presumably know
each squad is made up of two entirely
separate teams the offense and the
defense
when the possession of the ball changes
one team's offense and the other teams
defense charge off the field and their
counterparts rush on the field so that
the game can continue my friend was one
of those rare individuals who played
both offense and defense so while all
others were rushing to and fro he would
just stand there he would stand there
for a few moments with what seemed like
the whole world looking at him he had
that rare opportunity to contemplate in
public during those few moments he would
reflect on the hard work the sweat the
pain of what had just been accomplished
and contemplate the exhilaration of
working with new people in facing new
challenges in an entirely new
environment we of course find ourselves
in that situation today in these few
hours we contemplate with pride the
people and the achievements of the past
but we should also use this opportunity
for a realistic assessment of the state
of today's world for the professional
chemical engineer we should use this
time to think about the future and to
assess what will
expected of chemical engineers during
the next several decades most
importantly we should consider the
question what should our leading
academic institutions be doing about
preparing for the future but first let
me take my own brief look at the past
doc Lewis and his contemporaries in the
profession developed a curriculum
designed to deal with the creation of
new processes and the development of
businesses to commercialize those
processes faculty was selected for their
technical prowess to be sure but they
were also selected for a set of personal
skills that could have led to successful
industrial careers in the 30s and 40s
and 50s Chemical Engineering was the
most entrepreneurial of the engineering
disciplines since a chemical process in
its large specialized capital investment
could be obsoleted immediately by a
better idea the concepts of risk
analysis and management economics were
usually part of the formal curriculum
I remember ed Gill and then Tom Sherwood
telling me when I was a young faculty
member at the Institute in the 60s that
the pioneers in the field signed on
because they believed they had the
capacity to remake the commercial world
in a very fundamental way Ed's and Tom's
eyes would gleam as they described their
early plans for manufacturing synthetic
materials that would replace many of the
world's construction materials wood
steel aluminum were all in part to be
replaced by succeeding waves of polymers
composites and other new substances much
was accomplished but much of that
optimism was not fully realized the
traditional industries would
metallurgical paper and the like
developed new products and effectively
retaliated with their own innovations
the intellectual leadership of the
profession
turned either to a more exacting
analysis of processes that already
existed often using emerging
computer-based techniques or to to or to
new areas of technology during the 60s
for example we saw a great commitment to
the material sciences with particular
emphasis on catalysis or on newly
emerging applications based on polymer
membrane inventions or to creation
stemming from work in surface chemistry
frankly at about this time we were
struggling to attract the best young
technical minds through this field
arguably many of the best minds were
moving to the electronics field where
the miniaturization of electronic
circuits and the attendant software
developments were revolutionizing the
world that we all lived in to be sure in
our own field the 70 saw substantial
progress in environmental problems
electronic materials manufacturing in
automation and process design and
control but the process industries the
bread and butter of our profession had
grown to such a size that our blue chip
companies often performed financially in
accordance with the commodity type price
swings of their raw materials and
products Ralph has already alluded to
this in his remarks capital decisions
which previously had had a dominant
technological input were now more
heavily influenced by OPEC pricing
decisions or futures prices on Chicago's
commodity exchange our leading companies
employed their large cash flows by
diversifying into seemingly related
fields corporate leadership positions
started to become populated by lawyers
and MBAs rather than the scientists and
engineers who created these industries
most importantly the chemical and
metallurgical industries were lured in
many cases into backward integration
into energy assets and then were
whipsawed in the subsequent downdraft of
oil and gas prices during the 80s while
all this has been going on the pace of
scientific change has accelerated
there has been much new science to be
exploited by employing methods
traditional of the chemical engineer
modern chemistry is permitting more
thorough and exacting analysis of raw
materials and product mixtures this has
led to a much better understanding and a
potential for even better understanding
of reaction mechanisms additional
exciting applications are found in
semiconductor manufacturing and in
processing complex complex mixtures of
synthetic molecules from the laboratory
of the modern biologist now in the late
80s while the leadership of our
profession increasingly turns its
attention to the collection of emerging
applications described earlier by
Professor way the economic backbone of
our profession of our profession the
process Industries is under increasing
assault a group of businessmen and
opportunists again as described earlier
by Ralph have recognized the vulnerable
state of many of our domestic process
industries and have successfully gained
control of these enterprises it is well
known that the economic and financial
systems in Japan and Germany are more
conducive to long-term investment in
research and product and market
development these factors combined with
a lack of success in recent years in the
United States in diversifying many of
our chemical industries and catalyzed by
the very attractive currency exchange
ratios have produced unprecedented
interest in the acquisition of us-based
chemical and energy companies in
addition we in the United States have
spawned an even more lethal attack from
within this attack has been organized by
a sector of this nation's financial
community now our financial community is
composed of financial analysts lawyers
investment managers and investment
bankers and for the most part these
individuals diligently and competently
manage the assets of our country's
institutions and our citizens a portion
of this can
however is highly entrepreneurial some
would call these people financial
opportunists others would even turn them
financial manipulators or as in the case
of mr. Volsky and others financial
frauds and criminals these people have
been particularly attracted to the
values of our industry and it produced
remarkable speculative activity in
chemical stocks this speculation has
transferred to the financial community
an unprecedented degree of control and
the allocation of capital in the
ownership and even in the management of
America's chemical and energy
enterprises now I consider that the
younger members of today's financial
community to be among the most able
people of their generation many of our
most qualified young people in the
United States are increasingly attracted
to investment management to consulting
and to financial advising they do it
quite simply because that's where the
money is
I know because I used to hire them in my
previous job at fidelity and I will tell
you that they are highly motivated
exceedingly able and very aggressive now
this cadre on the whole is quite
critical of the management of many of
our chemical and energy companies in
this country they say that we have spent
millions on diversification and a little
to show for it they say that we have
lost our international market share
position in some of our principal
industries and they say that we have
been in some cases negligent in creating
growing values for those who own our
enterprises our shareholders the problem
of course is that there are strong
elements of truth in these criticisms
these observations explain our
automobiles industry's loss of its once
dominant world leadership position and
the consequent loss of our tire
industry's market share our best managed
chemical companies paid up to acquire
energy assets
at an inopportune time and for a number
of years our steel industry most often
made headlines for its vigor in
challenging the wisdom of America's
trade policies in turn all these events
have led to the now commonplace wave of
corporate restructurings leveraged
buyouts takeovers and ownership rates in
some it appears to me that one of the
most creative segments of this nation's
youth have been mobilized during this
past decade in a highly effective
assault on the industries created and
built by their parents generation many
members of that earlier generation were
graduates of this department in the
meantime the curriculum that we offer
our students has remained substantially
unchanged we as a department and we as
chemical engineering academics have
remained for all intents and purposes
above the industrial fray some would say
industrial turmoil is inherent in the
nature of technology-based industry a
process of renewal is essential I would
say that our graduates have been
brilliant in building technologically
based enterprises yet many of these
industrial organisms have remained
remarkably unadapted I ask you to think
about the status of Union Carbide
Phillips oil Firestone United States
Steel Gulf oil Texaco BorgWarner Conoco
the great names of my professional youth
and I'd like to think that I'm not that
old these are great companies which
either have not survived or they are
carrying on any much weakened condition
and as we think about these companies I
ask all of you my professional
colleagues how should we change the
nature of our academic enterprise so as
to produce poop people who not only
create
technologies and industries but who also
have the capacity to draw from the past
to drive the future to understand the
essence of modern Commerce as it is
increasingly practiced on a global scale
it has become become commonplace to say
that there no longer is really an
American industrial enterprise but only
a global one we must develop the
capacity to combine the strengths of the
past with the developments of today to
appeal to the clients of tomorrow when
Golf and Firestone are lost in forced
mergers we lose values and procedures
and productive human beings we must
produce students who can help create new
industry and develop and sustain
organizations that can compete adapt
survive and dominate their markets
worldwide Chemical Engineering is the
second of the engineering professions at
least in my view of things the second of
the professions to face this issue for
example civil engineering never really
had to cope with this situation bridges
and highways do not in general become
extinct for technical or competitive
reasons they simply were out in time and
are rebuilt or replaced using
contemporary technology on the other
hand industries based on mechanical
engineering have already been through a
similar evolutionary process and have
had Mick mixed success in my opinion the
economic woes of Detroit Pittsburgh
Toledo Akron and Warren provide ready
testimony to our nation's difficulties
in mechanical based industries over the
past decade now chemical engineers are
in the midst of the maelstrom and the
early cracks in the dike are becoming
apparent in our effort to maintain
America's worldwide domination in
electronics and computer hardware
technology and its attendant software
development opportunities IBM Intel dak
hewlett-packard
must now fend off competitive advances
from Japan Korea Taiwan and soon
probably from China and Russia Americans
are learning that breakthroughs and
research and development are not enough
we also need breakthroughs in the
technology of manufacturing of process
control which will lead to the
production of products having the
highest possible quality in the broadest
sense of that word
so I react the question what should this
department be doing about these problems
specifically what changes should be made
in our chemical engineering curriculum
it is out my own view that substantial
progress has been made in thinking about
it you've heard a summary of that
earlier in the day it is my further view
that our undergraduate curriculum is
already pretty fully committed as a
result of the conflicting pressures for
mastering an ever-expanding body of
technology while simultaneously
developing a real integrated sense of
the humanities and social sciences
however in the graduate curriculum
particularly our doctoral program I
believe there is real room for
improvement doctoral students presumably
have made a commitment to this
profession and many of them will end up
in positions of leadership in industry
or government our doctorate in
engineering is patterned after the
traditions of the Doctrine and cyant in
the sciences as more and more science
has become the focus of our engineering
doctoral degree in my judgment we have
lost sight of the concept that the
function of an engineer is to apply
science to solve problems of practical
significance as such I believe our
graduate students should be required to
develop at least some sense of global
economics marketing strategy product
differentiation
and patent law during the five years
that it takes a typical student to
complete his doctoral work shouldn't we
require that he or she be able to
interpret a balance sheet or an income
statement or to read intelligently a
corporate or government agency annual
report how about requiring that all of
our graduate students demonstrate some
oral proficiency in foreign in a foreign
language not the less demanding written
exams that we had in the past with our
students lack of exposure to financial
matters organizational dynamics and the
simple basics of sales and marketing
techniques we are producing players who
are entering a game where they are
really ill-equipped to compete
effectively in my view adequate exposure
to many of these issues can be provided
without unduly detracting from our
primary objective of technical
excellence in addition such exposure
would also enable us to provide for our
students a an element of career guidance
of a much higher order and it is my view
that this is an area where real
improvement would be welcomed by our
students having said this it is becoming
increasingly clear that the survivors of
our older companies in the chemical and
energy industries and the strategies of
our entrepreneurial companies must now
take into account the realities of a
truly global arena you will hear shortly
from my friend and former colleague
Lester Thurow who I am sure will discuss
the global nature of industrial
development and may describe some of his
efforts to bring a sense of technology
to MIT Sloan schools educational program
as you listen to his remarks think hard
about our own profession Dean Toros
managers will not be effective without
an appreciation of technology the
converse in my view is also true our
graduate chem
engineers will not excel in their
inevitable and rightful positions of
leadership unless we provide for them a
very different and broader approach to
their education and an expanded
definition of professional competence so
just as my friend recalled his past
glories on the football field we can
also reflect upon our own achievements
here today
these last hundred years have been
exceptional and have seen an unrivaled
procession of outstanding individuals
new technologies and industrial
enterprises but too many of these
industrial creations have not adequately
met the test of time as we contemplate
the future we need to know who I and we
need to adjust our educational
enterprise so that the institutions of
the next century will exhibit more
enduring values in an increasingly
international competitive and complex
marketplace thank you very much
[Applause]